I have a question do you feel like
Andrew Tate could have avoided all of
this if he would have just focused on
his wife rather than messing around with
like how many other women this question
I think you know because the thing is
the the cancellation came before this
they canceled it you know there's this
one dude that started posting stuff I
forget his name he's like it's like this
Gage wish that dude started like posting
this like you know Slide by like
infographic thing I'm like why Andrew
Tate is so misogynistic and then boom
one day you wake up Instagram Facebook
Twitter Youtube mind you are all
competitors unified together banned him
right that just shows you how afraid
they were of his influence and it wasn't
because of him cheat you know having
other women and stuff he was like oh
he's a misogynist symbol